I'm so sorry about this Yoda oh please
we're here to save the life of our
friend that is all
we paid her to help us get in and get
out you think that'd mean oh I'm gonna
help you do it in a way that no one
knows it's happening but no what she
means is I'm gonna shoot people threaten
people's lives
and I know you're probably asking why
would I trust her well that's a good
question
the answer is
we used to be in love yeah she was my
girlfriend only she doesn't remember it
because it wasn't her because her dad
threw off a magic clip and she died and
then I lost my temper and nearly
destroyed half the universe
and she came back out of the past there
she is
everyone else who died in the past
stayed dead not her why was it the magic
Cliff I don't know that's some freaking
infinity stone scientist
and some dumbass Earth dude who met a
girl fell in love
that girl died
and then came back a total dick
you left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it